homeboy gene Jeter has put together an
unnecessary censorship for the real
rejects hell yeah John's cringing again
don't know why you know it's creepy
but you know what I'm excited for John's
laughs whenever something funny happens
he's gonna do his Super Saiyan laughs
it's good I felt that always in my ear
stuff always in my left ear
okay I'm gonna pitch it to pop to the
corner of the room right on the ceiling
I go he goes all right all right guys oh
hey John yeah would you do the
introduction like I did on
hey do it hurry up Joker trailer drops
so here I'm still kind of chewing up
yeah I'm sort of with you in the sense
of that my favorite I don't know exactly
what I'm like all right but I've had
people actually could you how many guys
we got in here 94 that's plenty to kick
off it's it's done badly for the title
hey I'm wearing that shirt right now
what about Finn Adele's no like most
people who are gonna click on that
what's gonna be their main takeaway you
know here's the hotness is it really is
this supposed to make me go whew I
forgot that it was a done badly oh it's
alright it's alright
until that almost makes it better yeah
they all makes it a lot better now mix
it hey make a lot more sense but I made
the reaction better at the time yeah
that was an adventure
our first unnecessary censorship done
about us in a bad way but I like your
mix with it you had the music to it you
edited it like a fun weird compilation
assort you got creative with the amount
of beeps you threw in sequentially how
did you select them get some of this
footage is like very oh yes like a few
years old their apartment there's the
other beauty and we upload like more
than enough revenue so I don't know how
you managed did you like go off your
memory of of certain videos we did or
did you just look up random ass videos
and then watch just take the first one
yeah whatever pops up in your algorithm
when you type in the real rejects is
that the ones you went with because I
don't know how you decided upon which
one to do but hey I'm honored personally
don't do one like all the time but you
know periodically as milestones go by I
would love to see this series grow I
mean if you do this for other reactors I
bet they'll be reacting to it too don't
ya yeah I mean all you got to do is pick
an interesting I love genes whole mashup
series bit the piece to it cuz each one
has its own hook and so I think
unnecessary censorship done poorly or
wealth with fits really well here with
our aesthetic I think you ought to try a
one where you can do well because I
think you know how to source your
footage and I think you know timings
I would actually check out I would try
to do your own version that is done well
do it for other reactors like Tyrone
Magnus Arrakis ani you never know oh
they say plenty of stuff that could be
misconstrued as dirty and racist oh
definitely guys especially those two
especially witness I'm surprised it
hasn't affected their channel alright
guys we'll check out the gene jeter
youtube channel trust me it's worth your
time you should have called this
unnecessary censorship as an April
Fool's joke and then change it to done
badly the next day that way you could
wake up to a video full of nothing but
dislikes subscribe to gene Jeter is this
kind of their rejects see you guys soon